So I need to make some room in the freezers
for all the meat birds we have left to butcher.
So I'm gonna preserve the rest of the deer meat
we have in the bottom of the freezer.
So to preserve this deer meat,
I'm gonna make it into deer jerky.
I'm gonna start off by slicing it really thinly
with an extremely sharp knife.
This way,
the meat will dry out and preserve evenly.
The thinner the meat is, the better it will preserve.
Now, I'm gonna leave this to sit in the marinade for about six hours
before I put it in the dehydrator.
I was checking out the cookbook that it came with,
and I'm super interested in these dehydrated egg yolks.
I've never seen anything like that.
Then I'm gonna painstakingly lay each piece of meat out
flat onto the racks. I wanna make sure that the meat's not folded over,
so that way it will dehydrate evenly.
And I was gonna pop all the trays into the dehydrator
and let that sit at 1:65 for at least six hours.
I'm gonna keep coming back and check.
I don't want it to be over dehydrated where it's, like, brittle.
But I also wanna make sure it's all dried out,
otherwise it'll go moldy.
Once all the meat has dehydrated evenly,
I'm gonna put it into a ziploc bag.
And it should last a few weeks in the pantry,
but we normally eat there within a few Days